foreign
welcome back to the data science Hangout
if this is your first time joining it's
so nice to meet you I'm Rachel if you
want to say hi in the chat please do
the data science hangout is an open
space for the whole data science
Community to connect and chat about data
Science Leadership questions you're
facing and what's going on in the world
of data science
I like to remind everyone the sessions
are recorded and shared to the rst
YouTube and our data science hangout
site so you can always go back and
pre-watch or find sessions that you
missed too
we also have a LinkedIn group for the
hangout this also helps you find people
and connect with each other continue
discussions I'll share that in the chat
in just a second here
but together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming space for
everybody and we love when everyone can
participate and we can hear from
everybody so no matter your level of
experience or area of work
there's always three ways you can ask
questions you could jump in here by
raising your hand on Zoom
you can put questions into the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
there if you want me to read it out loud
instead or else I could just call on you
to introduce yourself and and add some
context
we also have a slido link where you can
ask questions anonymously and we'll
share that in the chat in just a second
here too
I just started adding this in because I
always reframe this as questions but if
you have something add to add to a
specific topic make your own perspective
to share on something we'd love to hear
that too
um and also wanted to mention that if
you are currently hiring we love to be
able to have people share those open
roles in the chat as well so feel free
to use those
uh that chat to share links we don't see
that as as spammy if you want to share
open positions there
but with all that I'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host for today Melissa
Perry senior manager e-commerce
analytics at Peloton and Melissa I know
you've been here in the audience quite a
few times so great to have you here as
our leader for today
um we'd love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe share a little bit
about your role and the work that you do
maybe also something you do in in your
free time as well
thanks Rachel
um thank you for having me I always
enjoy coming into this community and
hearing from the other leaders and
practitioners in this space so I'm
really pleased to be here today
um well uh we've been in
business intelligence and data science
for the majority of the last 10 years in
my career
I love helping leaders make decisions
it's um it's part of what I do just
taking a really complex environment and
I feel it's part of my purpose to help
people understand the truth and most
recently help people understand what's
coming and and what I recommend they
should do
uh because of what's coming so that's
where I really find my passion
um I've worked in many Industries I
started off my career in Toyota and
purchasing and and being in a very uh
quality driven manufacturing lean
environment and then I've I've also
worked in public education I've worked
in telecommunications and and I would
say that my role in telecommunications
is an analytics engineer that's where I
really kind of kicked off my obsession
with moving into data science and
learning how to automate decisions and
there was just data everywhere in my my
role at U.S cellular Corporation
um I also became an R user there Heavy R
user
um and and with that that exposure I
decided to level up my skills and pursue
a masters in data science while I was an
analytics engineer there I went to the
University of Eau Claire Wisconsin Eau
Claire and um just recently completed
that and I'm obsessed with uh this
problem of predictive maintenance it's
it's one of my passion areas how do you
help
um an organization predict when
something will fail and thus do all of
the activities Upstream to prepare for
that event I just love it
um but uh my most recent role as you
said has been coming onto the team at
Peloton I joined at the height of the
pandemic in February 2021 and I adopted
a a little pot of people called the
e-commerce analytics pod on our data
science team and we built a Dream Team
some of them are on the call today uh
just just great colleagues and friends
and just really smart people that are
passionate about helping our
stakeholders to make decisions around
gosh you name it extended warranty
um Diana's talking right now she has a
model called serial number event stream
where she helps predict when our bikes
will fail and helps our supply chain
team prepare for that and
um
gosh I I just can't say enough good
things um our referral program
um our member Support Agency how can we
help those folks to to provide our
members with a better post purchase
experience once they buy one of our
connected Fitness units
um
this has been a an incredible journey
for me because I stepped into formal
people leadership when I came onto
Peloton and not only did I take on a
team and get to work with all these
great people but it's no secret that uh
it's been a lesson in change management
for me
um heavy change management every three
to four months change management
um so I'm passionate about sharing with
you about that journey and and I'm happy
to answer any questions you might have
about what that's been like doing
analytics in that kind of environment
and building out my team so absolutely
yeah that's great thank you yeah I'm
excited to ask you more about that too
one part of the first question what's
something fun that you like to do in
your your free time outside of work too
oh cooking definitely cooking I am all
about the kitchen I'm um I like using
cookbooks I really like to be methodical
and you know get everything ready to go
so that I can enjoy myself while I cook
and kind of listen to music and things
but I work remotely and that's something
that I do in the evening that I just
love the ability to do that I love it I
noticed that a lot of people say cooking
on here maybe there's some relationship
between data science and cooking for
sure
um but I know thank you for for sharing
how you've been building the the Dream
Team and and I would love to learn a
little bit more while we're reading for
questions to come in about how you
approach growing and developing your
team
yeah absolutely
um so I
inherited some team members who were
already here there were two when I came
into the e-commerce analytics space
um and then I grew people
um I like a diversity and thought when I
approached building an analytics team so
we took folks with direct domain
experience and the member Support Agency
for interfacing with customers because I
was trying to improve that e-commerce
experience we thought well let's get
some folks that know it best they've
come from the front lines but they also
want to grow their career in data
science
so
I've grown people from that level and
then I also grow people who are kind of
mid-level and their data analysis career
and kind of get them to the next step so
how do you and and the most common pain
point is like and and I got here in my
career where it's like you you spend all
this time building dashboards or
building a presentation and then you're
like okay what next what are you going
to do with that
um and so I like to throw people over
that Loop and get them thinking about
how do I deliver insights how do I
deliver recommendations kind of like my
favorite part of it
um but I start you know pretty pretty
NASA at Peloton we have um in our
Central data science team we're kind of
like a a central uh a center of
excellence model and so we sit right
alongside our data engineering team and
there's quite a bit of Dev work that is
expected from our data analysts all the
way up to our data engineers and data
scientists that might not be expected on
all the other teams like that I'd work
for so I start real simple with folks I
I pull up the terminal I and we start
with you know Linux commands and things
like that and get and build from there
and then we start with Git you've gotta
you've gotta have some uh development
skill on our team and so we practice
what that means and kind of help them
understand that I'm about to throw you
for a loop here we're about to do some
things that are uncomfortable but it's
okay you know you're supported
um and you're gonna be fine and then
beyond that you know we start
um exposing our team members to
uh requests that come in that could be
helpful to folks like like reporting so
there's always a need at Peloton to help
people across the company understand
what's going on
um how many people are eligible for this
promotion or this particular
um
refund event because of where they are
in their post sale process so so there's
always opportunities like that where you
can really get a team member's hands
dirty early on
um and they can understand the data
warehouse the Mart
um use bi tools we use looker and
Tableau here at Peloton so
um how can you create that report and
then
um
after someone demonstrates their ability
there I start to
put them in front stakeholders more so
and and start to build that consult up
in the consult
for me is really based in um ensuring
they can do design thinking
and build empathy with that stakeholder
and start to recommend here's what
you're asking me for which typically
stops IT reporting right
um
but okay here's what I think you need to
be asking me
can you expand a bit on design thinking
and what what that means for your team
yeah
um
so
design thinking is an approach to really
getting to know people and their pain
points as you're trying to help them so
on my team we have
um really like
four to five strong stakeholder groups
where you know I I have a not a dotted
line but a real strong relationship with
a leader at Peloton so let's say it's
our extended warranty program
um I get to know what's bothering that
leader data wise like what is what is
what are you on the hook for what are
you struggling to measure how much are
you doing how well are you doing it like
what is your goal
and I try to help my team to build the
same level of consult and and empathy
with their counterparts on that leaders
team so that they can really provide
helpful Solutions with data
um and
that's been strong and it helps them
think about
how do they design their approach like
what is this model that we're going to
build really be able to do what are the
actions that this person is struggling
to do and how can I use data to help
with that so it's really kind of like a
brainstorming
activity but you're you're putting
yourself in the shoes of that
stakeholder getting to know them
figuring out how you could be most
helpful
I love that explanation thank you that's
so helpful I see there's a there's a lot
of questions starting to come in now and
one that came in on um slido was do you
share any best practices or Lessons
Learned From the e-commerce analytics
team like do you have a Blog for example
what we um
we do we have a couple things that we do
at Peloton that have really helped us to
communicate about our successes
um and we're going to be expanding upon
these but we have a newsletter that um
we we work with our our Central project
management team and we share our wins we
also share some things that we're
struggling with so we call like dirty
laundry
um it is just you know it's a startup so
nothing's perfect at Peloton
um but we share how we're we're working
through some of those issues and then my
favorite thing that we do is we have
what we call a data Town Hall
and because we're that Central analytics
team
um sometimes it can be hard to have that
sense of community with all the other
analytics teams that are at Peloton
helping make decisions
um so we stood up the state of town hall
event and and we had presenters from the
e-commerce analytics space that talked
about some of our most exciting models
um like Diana Morrell who's on the call
spoke about her serial number event
stream model and all the use cases that
have come from that and and kind of
showcase this design thinking element
and and how she thinks like a data
scientist those kinds of opportunities
are really powerful
um and and in that same data Town Hall
we also talked about tech stack we
talked about
um programming approaches to
um ensure that our data models are well
taken care of and documented for others
um and made sure that people knew how
our data engineering stack was evolving
so those are not only in the e-commerce
analytics space but but a place where
yes
um we we share that now if you're asking
me externally if we post
um we do not at this time but I'm always
encouraging my team to blog and and
share their great work
that's awesome I really like the idea of
the the data like Town Hall event how
often does the team do those
no it's a quarterly thing at this time
um we're we're a distributed team and uh
resources are tight and and especially
right now with the state of the economy
um but but right now we plan to do that
quarterly
cool I see Millie you put a question
into the chat just a little bit ago do
you want to ask that
um live on the call sure yeah hey
Melissa um yes I'm like newer to the
e-commerce space I'm coming from higher
education and I'm now currently working
as a senior data analyst at thinks and I
was like wondering if you since you also
recently like completed a degree if you
have any like recommended like
e-commerce specific
um resources or communities that you
like to reach out to so I can like uh I
guess catch up on the the metrics and
lingo and the analytics world and
e-commerce
you know that's a really good
um
that's a really good question Millie hi
welcome to the group
um and congratulations to you all taking
this step in your career and and trying
something new that's just that's just so
admirable
um and uh yeah I'm familiar with thanks
as well very cool company yeah you know
I am not uh I I think there's a few
there's a few particular areas where you
might go out and and find
um some some critical kpis for
e-commerce
um I would just research that like I
would anything else like like Googling
it
um but but what I can say is that like a
Peloton and in my team specifically
although my title is e-commerce
analytics I don't
um and my team never analyzed the
kinds of metrics that you would think we
would so it's always been kind of this
misnomer like for e-commerce analytics
Millie one of the
um
key metrics but this is really like for
an engineering based team
so it depends like if your team is
engineering based and trying to
constantly improve the engineering of
your page or if it's like more business
facing and you're just trying to do
things like
report and help people understand the
transactions like the sales transactions
so my team kind of played on that ladder
role where we're helping Executives
understand the state of sales and post
sale activity for the members
um but like conversion rate
that's one of the key metrics in
e-commerce like in the broader Community
that's really an engineering facing uh
metric at Peloton because all of the
changes that those engineers make they
want to see okay is am I driving
conversion am I getting more sales
through making this particular change on
the website so um that's one that I
would definitely start to familiarize
yourself with and
um you may you may end up finding a
community and sharing with me
um some of the some of that information
Millie I wish I could be more helpful to
you
oh good thank you
I was just writing into the chat too I
would love to try and gather some more
retail examples that that we've seen too
and I'm thinking about the uh hangout a
few weeks back with Jay from Harry Rosen
as well that might be a helpful one to
check out
um I see a few other slido questions
coming in too and
um
and one is what are some of the biggest
challenges of working with non-technical
stakeholders
yes
um so
one of the challenges
um first is communication
and figuring out how to resonate with a
non-technical stakeholder when
your team and those that are working
with you are primarily technical
um you have that challenge of building
trust trust is the first
that that's the biggest thing right they
have to have an awareness and a belief
that you are doing everything you can to
provide that data product that's going
to help them do better and so
um
I do think it does go back to that
design thinking that empathy and the
having enough humility to ask people
what how can I really help you be better
and not having that belief
um as an analyst that you know all the
answers because let me tell you you do
not
um numbers and and data are only
modeling what we have them model that
they're a representation of the truth
but on the ground
um operationally there's always so much
to learn
and you've got to really build those
relationships with the folks that are on
the ground that you're trying to help
um
so they know you care
so they just need to care and I think
once you get over that hurdle and they
know that you're trying to help them be
a better version of themselves and do
better at work
then you've gotten that inroads to start
passing them okay here's this report
that you were asking for you know how
can we make this better or hey you know
I see you're really struggling with this
here's did you know that this is the the
journey that you're on and you've made
this much improvement or
you know what um it looks like we're
getting worse in this area I'm seeing
I'm seeing a negative Trend here so
um
it's really trust first then
communication and figuring out like to
what extent do you need to feel like
read into that person's technical
capability and like dial back all the
things that you know because and this is
the hardest thing for me to tell my
people
um it's like I care about your Technical
know-how and your technical progression
but your stakeholder oftentimes does not
especially if they are a non-technical
person it just overwhelms them and if
you're talking about
um programs that you're using or or the
statistical elements and you're not
being careful about how you're
um
positioning that it can become very
unapproachable very quickly
so it's definitely a uh it's a soft
skill
um and an area that that must be
developed in order to truly get use
cases into production
okay thank you
I see that
um uh family apologies if I'm
pronouncing your name incorrectly ask
the question into the chat and I'm not
sure if you're still on so I'm going to
ask it live but feel free to jump in and
add context too but the question was how
do you identify data loss due to system
issues they said that's part of my job I
find very stressful
okay
so data loss due to systems issues it's
so funny because we had a situation like
this come up yesterday
so I think
um with that now I will say this is not
what I do in my everyday today role but
I but I've done this role before
um earlier on and I think it's a matter
of
laying out and understanding the
architecture first of the systems that
are supposed to talk to one another
so when you understand the process flow
and the lineage of the data as it moves
through let's say from your customer
so let's say your customer enters in
their name on your website
and then you go and you are
um assessing the next system that that
is integrated with that uh and supposed
to receive that and and perhaps the name
didn't flow over well to what extent is
that happening because in complex
systems sometimes it's going to come
over and sometimes it isn't so I think
in many cases it's it's a means of
pulling data out of both of those
systems that are allegedly supposed to
talk to each other in some way and then
seeing what went and what didn't
um a lot of times that there's an there
could be an integration issue there or
there could be a separate business
process that's flowing and then like
it's not writing so I think it's really
a matter of of taking a step back
understanding the flows that you have
uh assigned on your data collection
process to really assess like where is
that data expected to go and then where
should I be seeing a one for one match
um we got to make sure we know that part
first uh before we say it's lost
all right thank you
deepshat I see you're asked uh actually
two great questions into the chat do you
want to jump in and ask those
sure and I think one of the questions
you almost have answered it already but
you talked about having so many projects
uh how do you prioritize between them
and the second question is
um which What proportion of these
projects are stakeholder driven versus
you think oh this we know the product so
we think this would be a good idea and
then reaching out to your stakeholders
thinking you have a project idea which
one of these usually tend to get more
traction
yeah this is such a great question thank
you so much for asking it
um and you're catching me at a place in
a space at Peloton where I am
reassessing everything that my team does
um so we're going through times of
radical change and and that is
um something that every leader is gonna
face like what should we be doing
um I will tell you the truth and be
super transparent with you
um our data science team has been really
in alignment with various stakeholder
teams almost 30 teams across the company
so we've played that role
cross-functional role and almost like a
service provider role for um as long as
I've been here and you know we've really
jumped in and filled in holes where as a
startup Peloton was coming up and there
was no infrastructure or no data
collection or no no one to really
provide this service
um to the company and we we raised our
hand
and we have
um lots of models that kind of reflect
our best effort
to make these decisions
and that has been my top priority so far
you know when I came in you know it was
taking in
um use cases like extended warranty and
and cleaning that up and and you know it
was very clear like that's your top
priority
but you know as we kind of
take a step back and and really think
about
um how we can add value to Peloton
sometimes those things uh get
de-prioritized
and you start to think about no no no
what is the cross-functional data
science team really need to do
how do we really tell
um
our c-suite what's going on and what
they should do
um and just like it's
it's really exciting in a turnaround and
I think what has happened because of the
turnaround situation is we've seen a new
group of leaders that use data
holistically in ways that our leadership
team before didn't and so as you see
them using these new data points you
start to get inspired about like well if
they knew this then they could do X
right if you knew what the lifetime
value of each customer from each channel
of sales was then you could figure out
where to invest in more
um and and and maybe that's the right
role for the cross-functional data team
that doesn't really have a dog in any
operational fight to be playing
and um I I think that that's where
at least I'll be speaking to my new
leadership about changing the priority
but but that's what what has happened so
far does that help you that does make
sense thank you yeah
I love hearing how excited you get
talking about like the business making
decisions with data too
I see um someone asked anonymously on on
slido what advice would you give to
someone who wants to transition from an
individual contributor role to a manager
role in data science
yes
um so I have been here
um I think when you're ready and you
want to try it you should raise your
hand and express yourself that's the
first piece of advice you need to tell
your leader
um you need to tell your Mentor
hopefully you have a mentor who is
that's another piece of advice is to get
a mentor that might be doing that work
that you want to do and start to talk to
them hey how did you get here what did
you do
um so that you have that different
advice coming in from different
perspectives and you're getting checking
yourself because that's a big hurdle
that is such a big hurdle to Claire
moving from that IC role to a manager
it's a very vulnerable state so get
someone else who's in your corner who
can help you on that process but yeah
raise your hand and get a mentor who's
who's already doing it
um and then the third piece of advice is
to brace yourself for
um like a year year and a half of
constant change and wrestling with your
own brain because it's really difficult
to take your hands off the keyboard
and um so I would say to give yourself
some Grace in doing that nobody gets it
right
um in the first in in that transition
period like there's always going to be
stumbling points where you're going to
make a mistake or you're going to step
on somebody's toes you're going to make
one of your ICS feel like you're
micromanaging and you're really not
you're just trying to make sure it goes
well but give yourself some Grace and um
use that mentor to help you navigate
those issues
foreign
I really like what Libby just added into
the chat as well on this topic too I
don't know if Libby you want to jump in
with that
um sure I don't know if anybody else has
this experience but being
maybe specifically a woman being a kid
who's like me can always told to like be
quiet and not be a bother to anybody
it was a huge lesson for me as I moved
through my life that I actually had to
verbalize and ask for what I wanted no
one was gonna just hand it to me because
I deserved it I had to say hey I want to
do this can I do this
and that leaves you very vulnerable and
open to somebody saying no we're saying
that they didn't they didn't think they
don't think you're ready or whatever it
is but you you consider and spin your
wheels forever if you don't at least ask
or put it out into the universe that you
want it in some way
Libby I want to respond to that and and
just um relate back to the room because
um when I first raised my hand um I
heard no
and um
I had that Mentor who was in in my ear
saying but you're ready
and Peloton said yes
and so did other companies too so just
because you hear that no doesn't mean
that the universe doesn't want you to do
that I love the way you said that Libby
and it's so important for everyone to
hear
so the person who asked that go for it
go for it and try it
definitely thank you all and and I see
somebody else ask an anonymous question
that was do you have any tips for
leading a team whose primary language is
not yours so for example I'm taking a
role and the team uses SAS and python
whereas my background is r
hmm
that's really interesting thought
um
well I guess
I guess primarily
um
I would if I were put in that situation
I would truly take the Strategic
approach and try to try to start by
asking that team like
what is it that you're working on what
is the value and the output that you're
delivering and like what do you think we
should fix to make it better and kind of
see
where it is that they want to kick up in
like what would give them more energy
and see how you can play a small part so
maybe you have to spend a little bit of
time learning like enough to be
dangerous in the tool that they use and
that's really just so you can review
their code and you know assess like hey
is this done uh correctly given the
business requirements it's so easy to
kind of
um when you're programming make a
different assumption or or generate an
output that is not what you intend
um the other thing I would recommend is
to just try to put on that hat of like
tool agnosticism where you start to
learn multiple of these programming
languages and get comfortable with the
fact that you don't know any of them and
oh by the way no one else knows all of
them in their head that's the secret
everyone else is Googling at work every
day and so even if you're struggling to
review that code
be comfortable going hey I don't know
this like let me Google what they did
here and read some of those docs and see
like does that make sense okay
you'll get your confidence about you
like as you start to do that more but I
would say don't shy away from what
they're doing even if it's in a
different language like try a little bit
and see like first assess like what's
the area that they really need your help
in they probably don't need you sitting
there coding by them they probably need
you to address something bigger
can always review their code and and get
your feet under you even if you don't
know the language
thank you
and and I see Brian I'm I think this was
in relation to this question as well but
you shared some thoughts in the chat too
if you want to jump in
and I think it was
oh there you go you needed two there's
Two Brians here I'm not sure which Brian
so me
uh somebody said so
trust your people and your job to make
yup that was me yeah that was the the
it's a big transition from
individual contributor it to leadership
is all about that
um
you your job is to make sure your people
have the tools and time to do the job
and that's it and you have to figure
that out like
it's not about having check-ins with
them every week or
all this other stuff
and
it's really about
um you are now the interface between
them and Leadership
and if it goes well that's great and you
give your team credit if it doesn't go
well it's on you it's not on your team
it's on you as a leader so that's that's
where people that's why I see rookie
leaders run into trouble first sign a
problem they'll pass the block
you can't do that and as soon as you do
that your people will not trust you
and you will become a terrible leader
you you just they'll hang you out to dry
without without you even knowing it and
they even know it because they realize
they don't trust you
right
um
and and so as a leader you have to have
that con that in you you're the buffer
absolutely how old is that Brian
and going through to the chat to see if
there were questions I missed over here
but I know there are a few others coming
through on slido too
um but just want to remind people if you
joined a little bit later that we have
the slido where you can ask questions
anonymously and Tyler can share that
link again but also just feel free to
raise your hand here on Zoom to jump
into
um but one of the other questions
Melissa was can you tell us more about
the development of your team in parallel
to the tech stack
yeah so
um the tech stock we have at Peloton
here is uh we use SQL these AWS redshift
for most of our data manipulation work
um we'll use looker as a bi front-end
tool as well as Tableau for some of our
reporting work that gets done and then
um as we go further then um just the the
bi work we use jupyter notebooks in
Python to do our coding
uh and of course like as I said earlier
all of this work our development process
requires a little bit of Dev because you
you do need to share your work in a
repository so that others can use it
that's kind of the way that's kind of a
principle on which we operate
and and manage changes
so
um
folks are coming to my team at all
stages and abilities with that
um I expose them to the tooling based on
where they can add value in the moment
so it's
um if if there's a tool like Tableau
where I know it's so complex that you
can't just sit down and start like we
will pursue formal training so we would
you know figure out how many licenses or
you know in our with our license
structure and how much training and
development can we provide to our people
but um if it's something like that
they're gonna get
um
advice to to sit for a training like
that
um when it's a tool like looker that's
kind of more approachable on the front
end you know I might you know sit and
help them through uh working in that
tool
um and and we we do some internal
training as well when it comes to like
helping somebody make this shift uh into
R and python I do personally recommend
um kind of stepping away from work and
learning through a class or a boot camp
where you're kind of
um making sure that you understand the
foundations of what's going on or like
in our I learned um through the swirl
Library how to you know just program and
and get answers out of out of our and
and I think doing exercises like that at
work and and through your work um
through the the educational resources
that are provided by your HR team
um if if you're lucky enough to have
those like
go take that class go take that boot
camp
um and and really understand what's
going on that's appropriate for your
role you know we want to help people
understand okay this is what your role
is and so with that these are the kind
of tasks that a data scientist will do
and so you need to learn how to do this
much in python or R
um whereas you know if you want to learn
how to pipeline data I'm going to send
you over to my colleagues right because
because I'm not really good at that and
and I'm pretty open about that so
um
uh but yeah I I always
um recommend further education but I do
I I am open and honest with my team
because I think you know when you're
when you're busy and you've got a lot of
work to do sometimes that's really
difficult to hear as an individual
contributor like oh I'm asking you to do
more
um we'd also try to provide education in
fun ways at Peloton like we have one of
my colleagues will he had this idea to
do a data labs
um concept where anybody on the team can
come up with this idea like I wish
somebody was working on this at Peloton
and I'm being honest with you it could
be a PM
and if they just want to try their hand
at solving a data science problem and we
create a space for that where we kind of
nurture the problem
um help them work through it with the
resources we have and and Coach them up
so they could get their feet wet and get
some exposure and get excited about data
science even if it's not their main job
that sounds great I love the data Labs
idea
I see um thank you Libby for being an
extra set of eyes for me but um David
you had your hand raised earlier for
your question you want to jump in
foreign
thanks my I'm a first timer here
um welcome technology veteran kind of
you know in that chronically
underemployed Set uh but I enjoy uh
working so much that um these things are
really exciting to me I volunteered in
the chat uh essentially what I wanted to
say was
um
you know uh the work-life sustainability
is really important and sometimes new
managers uh don't see it coming that
somebody's going to be leaving the team
and you end up with a gap in the team
and everybody has to pull up the slack
um one of the best ways to uh get your
team's trust and your organizations to
trust is to make sure that you have the
capacity to get things done uh so you
know you always under promise and over
deliver uh and You Gotta Be You Gotta
Have people uh around you in order to do
that as a manager thanks
absolutely
wow very timely for me
um and yes yes to all that you said
thank you
I think I see you had a question you had
a question in there too David maybe at
in the one in the chat do you want do
you want to ask that too
I'm not sure I asked a question okay I
think it was
um
somebody asked who are you grooming okay
let's yeah those are questions for the
manager okay who are you grooming to
join and how are you Paving away
absolutely yes yeah the managers uh
Focus moves from doing the work to
um creating the environment for the work
to get done
definitely
see let me go check over to slido Tyler
are there any questions that we maybe
missed on slido oh Javier I see you have
your hand raised jump in
yeah thanks uh and Melissa I really like
your insights
um thanks for sharing everything so I'm
just curious about
you know in my experience I feel like
some of the best data scientists that
I've worked with that have left the
companies
um have just gotten bored so
you know things in our space are moving
so fast as is
how do you
continue to give you know motivated
employees who want to continue to learn
you know the opportunities for learning
because once they start plateauing or
feel like they're not really learning
anything new
um despite them being more of an add
value to their current employer it you
know they themselves start looking
elsewhere so I don't know sort of an
open-ended question
yeah
yeah um one of the very first things I
do with my team and I apologize I forgot
to mention that it's when um
I started talking about how do I develop
people because we were talking like more
technical earlier but one of the very
first conversations I have with my
people is like where are you going after
you leave me because inevitably like
we're not going to work together always
right but I my job like because I'm so
people oriented is like how do I make
sure that this experience and this
relationship is beneficial for the both
of us and I think in order that's the
conversation where you start to figure
out what's motivating people like when I
came to Peloton I shared with my leader
like I really want to work on figuring
out how to get use cases into production
I've been struggling with that for years
like that was something that I said but
I've got people on my team that are like
you know what I want to be a data
scientist so I'm like okay well
um let me go figure out how to get out
there and find them work
and so through my relationships and
helping them empathize with people
um and figure out what their problems
are we find use cases
um and I am like kind of out there
talking about their work how they've
done such a great job on this dashboard
thing but you know really what I'm
hearing is that you're really trying to
make this decision and so like let's
just use extended warranty as an example
my team is delivering great reporting on
um sales and claims for third-party
warranty provider but you know I had a
data scientist sitting on the sideline
that said you know what if we could
predict who was best positioned to buy
an extended warranty and I said go for
it
don't just sit there go for it
um and so I kind of have them work on
that the background and then I go and do
the politicking to go hey James I've got
something for you we're doing all this
on the side that you've asked for but
you know what I had a person that was
really curious
and um they were curious about
delivering this kind of value why don't
you check it out
and because we've done so much on the
front end to answer that first question
and deliver value of what they actually
asked they'll receive it and then that
use case continues to grow and then it
gets into prod if we're lucky
um and that use case actually got turned
into a feature that is used for
marketing
so one way or another that's where it
comes from and then that person grows
and then their mind grows their eyes
open and then here they continue now
they're a data scientist
that's amazing I love to hear about the
way that you're you're advocating for
all the people on your team internally
to get there
I see uh Michelle you had a great
question in the chat do you want to jump
in
foreign
yeah um I was just curious
um about how your data org broadly kind
of draws the line between data
engineering data science and data
analysts
and then for a particular use case that
requires more
data modeling and pipelines from let's
say like a raw data source that the
company hasn't touched yet how do you
collaborate with data Engineers to
um deliver that value to the stakeholder
yeah this is great
um and my teammates here around the call
are probably smiling because we work
together we work together with um
that Center of Excellence team we sit
right next to the data engineering team
that's one of the reasons I wanted to
come to Peloton because
um our Center of Excellence team is uh
has that like 15 16 person data
engineering Squad and they are filled
with
um data Engineers uh who are doing
everything from getting data out of uh
like pulling Events off of our Kafka
streaming and bringing it into the lake
and then you have folks that are doing
your
um traditional ETL modeling as well as
elt modeling they have analytics
Engineers as well who are more so like
alongside the data analysts in the space
like the data analyst being the first
Folks at the front lines who are
listening and talking to the business
so I mean the way that we are if you
think of it in a cycle you have your
stakeholder up first and then your data
analyst like has that really close
relationship with someone on that
stakeholder team and they're saying okay
well these are like the requirements and
this is the problem I'm trying to solve
and then like let's say you need a new
pipeline well that is probably going to
be built like in its first pass by an
analytics engineer from our data science
or from our data engineering side of the
house
um and we get something like
uh MVP going and then uh after that like
we start thinking about okay do we need
to evolve this model is there is there
something that needs to be improved on
the engineering side of the house
um to make this more efficient and so
our services team might get involved
beyond that then you're um thinking
about okay here we've delivered this
you've got your dashboard you're seeing
it what's next for you what decision are
we making here and that's when our data
scientists come in and they begin to
start modeling that decision and
outputting the results
um and we would work with once we're
sitting on those results we would
visualize them assess the quality
and beyond that you're figuring out
where to pipe that service
I mean where do you take that answer and
serve it up because
you know the results of that decision
might not be best in a dashboard
especially if you're delivering it to
somebody in a warehouse maybe we need to
pipe it into that warehouse tool so we
have another set some of our data
Engineers are like more uh generalized
they can do it all like they're amazing
and so they would write services for us
I hope that helped that's how our shop
runs
um
we also collaborate with other people
across Peloton though you know there's
folks in it who are configuring I.T
systems and that people are touching and
sometimes it's just a matter of like
Landing data in redshift and getting it
picked up from another team it really
depends really depends Michelle but
that's a that's a fabulous question
thank you
um I see well I actually had one quick
question too I I know you mentioned the
center of excellence a few times and I
was I was just curious to learn more
about like what that Center of
Excellence is and if that's a model that
you recommend for other teams too
yeah you know what I'm sure other
leaders on the call are smiling because
um I think
you know I've I've worked
um in an in an embedded role before and
loved it
um Center of Excellence let's let me
just Define what I mean by that I mean
that there's a team of folks in what we
call the data science team or the data
and analytics team and they serve the
business in this like Central function
they're providing Frameworks the tech
stack places to document things process
structure training training on the tech
stack like expertise
um and then beyond that you've got
other analytics teams that are
throughout the company that are also
trying to make their lead help their
leaders make decisions but probably more
rapidly more rapid fire they would
utilize the expertise and the tech stack
from the central team to help their
leaders and um usually their leaders
want things yesterday and you know that
Central team doesn't necessarily have
the capacity to like intake and work all
that but they do have the capacity to
keep things clean and organized and so
that's really what I mean by that how's
that working at Peloton well we're
continuing to evolve our story there
um I think you know we're in a space now
where we've got a little bit of a
patchwork going on
um we're you know growing out of a
startup phase and that's natural and so
hone it all in and then send it all back
out with our new leadership so
um and what I mean by honing it all in
is like getting everybody realigned
um building those relationships
standardizing some of those
relationships with the the teams that
are depending on that Center of
Excellence so it's a lot of work
um but good work
um important for a company of our size
to get alignment that way your leaders
don't have multiple versions of the
truth
I mean thank you that's really helpful
I see I think Libby you put a question
into the chat just a few minutes ago do
you want to jump in
yeah
um my question was what made you want to
make that initial shift from Individual
contributor to People Eater in the first
place
um and did you have any concerns or
reservations going into that leadership
Journey where you were like okay let's
try this I'm worried about these things
what did that look like for you
yeah
um very very good question uh I realized
very quickly
um when I was like a business analyst
working in education that I like people
like I like seeing other people do
good work improve their work using data
like get more strategic be more
successful I like using data in that way
but I recognized very quickly that as an
IC I wasn't necessarily the one that was
achieving that I saw my leaders doing
that like I saw them rubbing elbows and
doing the politics to like get the data
in use
and then I'm like okay I want to learn
how to do that because I got this fresh
I got to this point of frustration where
it's like how many dashboards can I
build before you know I my brain just
explodes and nobody listens and what are
they even doing with this data and why
would they do that and how does this
company even make money you know what's
the strategy here
um and I just found you know my
background's in economics I just cared
more about that I just cared more about
that social element of it in helping the
work become a success making value out
of the work than I did actually touching
the keyboard now don't get me wrong
every once in a while I'll pick up a
ticket and Just Vibe like
it's a flow you know when you're doing
something
um I still feel that way sometimes when
I do some work
um so I'm still a nerd I still like to
talk about
um how to model things and what data
goes in but I wanted to do it from a
different angle and as I also like to
help my stakeholders do better I really
like to grow people's careers that like
that's like Nirvana for me once I can
see somebody that analyst grow from a
data scientist that was like a crowning
moment I'm like okay yeah this is right
now um like I said I had people tell me
no when I first
um stepped out as a leader
um I don't know if you've ever heard
you're she's not technical enough that
was funny
um had to work through that
um still a trigger point for me because
you know here I am I'm I'm I'm social I
like to help people and then so it you
know called into question my my
technical ability well that that wasn't
very good for the ego or the confidence
um but I've worked past that
um in a weak point sometimes I'll go
there and have that imposter syndrome
um
but it's my it's my people and my
stakeholders that build me back up
get that feedback like this is really
helpful
so yeah I would say that that was the
biggest
hurdle that I faced now and and I did I
did pursue more education because I did
realize that my skills had atrophied um
at like that business analyst layer and
I couldn't progress I couldn't go
further into the analytics engineering
or the data science and truly be able to
produce
um or understand what those people do so
I did pursue more education to address
that
awesome thank you
that's so incredibly helpful Melissa I'm
thinking about
like wanting to actually change the
strategy there and figure out how to how
to make the business better getting to
that point I um I remember when we were
talking
briefly before the hangout something we
were going to discuss which I didn't I
know we didn't talk about yet was what's
the biggest need that you have to
address in peloton's data science
community
foreign yeah I think right now it's
um
establishing one source of Truth and
gaining alignment like when we were
talking earlier about the center of
excellence it's like refining and truly
being a thought leader for what does
that mean for how we behave how we how
we treat one another how we communicate
and talk to each other about data
what does it mean for evolving thought
leadership around Concepts like data
governance you know at a fast-moving
company like Peloton you say data
governance like people are
what do you mean like you're about to
Slow Me Down You're about to say this
and this and I'm like no like we
literally we can't like
um you have to give these folks over
here a shot you have to listen and I'm
listening and and I'm gonna adopt this
and I want you to too so like I think
it's figuring out how to show up in the
center of excellent space and
bring along all my colleagues I've got
like 30 stakeholder teams and like
figuring out how to have them show up in
the space and and truly work together
like like a Peloton you know
uh I'm sure I'm not the only person who
like you know your company culture says
one thing and then you get into the data
space and it's like a completely
different thing
um but we can probably all laugh on the
inside about that
thank you so much I think we did a
pretty good job of capturing everything
thank you so much Melissa for joining us
it's been so fun and really love getting
to hear your insights and and your
experience
really appreciate it absolutely
absolutely thanks for having me this is
such a joy and I can't wait to see um
the folks that present in the coming
weeks um
thank you all yes thank you and next
week we will be joined by Jessie Pluto
who works at Comcast can't remember
title right off the top of my head right
now but really excited to see you all
next week as well thank you so much
Melissa and thank you all for all the
great questions as always have a great
rest of the day